today we're playing until dawn  apparently it's a scary video game I've  made a mistake oh my God we're gonna die  we're gonna die we're gonna guys she's  gonna die first I'm gonna shoot the  squirrel oh I thought that was when we  would both a hundred percent agree on I  [Applause]  [Music]  hate all these kids  I hate crows though I'm so afraid of  football I was just dancing that's what  I was doing the first time I would've  lost the doors open and closed it's just  I just a plant it's just a palm tree so  glad inferno for men  not as cheap yeah  Oh someone just screams a woman I'm  trying to thank goodness we had him jump  down bird listen I'm more upset about  the birdbrain joke oh my god it just  said status update you made a mistake  don't  it's a prank  to keep out strangers